ciao ragazzi ciao ragazzi e benvenuti
il video di oggi è un video che in
realtà volevo fare già da un po di tempo
però voglio trovare il momento giusto
perché oggi è il momento giusto perché
negli ultimi giorni l'ultimo periodo ho
analizzato meglio la situazione il
fenomeno e ho capito che la situazione
sta veramente degenerando visto che la
maggior parte delle persone che mi
seguono sono giovanissimi e questo
fenomeno riguardo appunto loro ho
pensato che fosse doveroso fare un video
a riguardo sto parlando del
cyberbullismo
per chi non sapesse cosa di cosa sto
parlando cyberbullismo appunto il
bullismo dei social insomma i bulli che
a scuola ti insultano lo fanno anche
dietro lo schermo anche e soprattutto
dietro lo schermo sotto le foto sotto i
tuoi video eccetera eccetera
piccola premessa per chi non mi seguisse
su instagram spesso nelle mie storie di
instagram punto mi piace condividere con
chi mi segue dei pareri delle opinioni
dire la mia insomma su varie polemiche
che possono assenti google nel web
insomma sulle tematiche del giorno
perché perché mi piace insomma
condividere le mie opinioni con con chi
mi segue
innanzitutto perché mi piace lo scambio
di pareri quindi il fatto che tu magari
la pensione in maniera diversa il
confronto queste cose mi sono sempre
piaciute le ho sempre trovate
interessanti e stimolanti ma soprattutto
il fine principale per il quale io parlo
di tematiche spesso sociali come la
violenza il bullismo è soprattutto far
arrivare dei messaggi a chi mi segue far
arrivare dei messaggi a chi magari è
vittima di violenze di bullismo e
non riesce a reagire o ha paura di
parlarne insomma è il mio modo indiretto
in realtà vuole arrivare direttamente lì
al punto alle persone che che mi seguono
e che hanno bisogno del mio sostegno
però sinceramente mi sono resa conto
della gravità del problema da quando ho
iniziato a usare music hall in music ari
per chi non lo conoscesse è una sorta di
social punto usato molto dai giovani
dove si può ballare cantare la sua
verità dentro 2.0
nato soprattutto per fare insomma del
labiale delle canzoni più famose
accompagnato magari da jesse che
spiegano appunto significato di quello
che si dice sono una roba molto carina
molto divertente conto ludica ho notato
che sia sotto i miei music ari che
ovviamente non sono una professionista
visto che lo uso da un mese neanche sia
soprattutto sotto i musicali di altri
bambini ragazzi insomma ho analizzato
molto molto bene la cosa
ho notato tantissimi insulti pesanti
cattivi da parte soprattutto di appunto
giovanissimi di bambini cioè andando a
vedere i profili di queste persone mi
sono reso conto che veramente si parla
di lattanti 6 7 8 anni quello che penso
e che alla base del bullismo e del
cyberbullismo ci sia
purtroppo la colpa dei genitori perché
un genitore che lascia uno smartphone
nelle mani di un bambino
sapendo benissimo i pericoli che ci sono
nel web nei social la violenza il sesso
c'è di tutto qualsiasi schifezza esiste
al mondo si può trovare
nel web e sui social anche dei tuoi sono
casi di pedofilia di pedofili che
adescano sui social quindi veramente
lasciare uno smartphone ha un bambino
senza controllare ogni singolo movimento
che fa all'interno dei social se proprio
bisogna fargli avere i social
trovo che sia veramente una cosa molto
molto molto preoccupante secondo me
questi cyber bulli questi bulli sono
semplicemente dei bambini con enormi
carenze d'affetto che si sentono soli
insicuri e si ritrovano con uno
smartphone davanti che pensano che sia
giusto tra virgolette sfogare questa
loro insicurezza questa loro
frustrazione risultando magari coetani
che vedono più coccolati più seguiti dai
genitori con più amici magari che vanno
meglio a scuola e un loro modo diciamo
di di sentirsi meglio questa la cosa
grave si sentono bene a far star male
gli altri
il problema però qual è e che non è
finita lì la questione non è che
cyberbullo insultavo finita lì problemi
suoi
bastano perché quello che fa lui si
riflette poi sulla vita degli altri
il suo essere insicuro e trovare
sollievo nel insultare gli altri crea
problemi alle persone che insulta porta
ad avere dei traumi a quelle persone che
magari avevano vissuto la loro
adolescenza fino a quel momento
benissimo non aveva nessun tipo di
problema arriva al bullo di turno e poi
iniziano i problemi per quale motivo tu
puoi creare problemi a gente che non ne
ha o che magari ne ha e non ne vuole
altri fa pensare insomma i bambini che
doveva la loro età dovrebbero giocare
studiare andare al parchetto con gli
amici
o usare i social in maniera divertente
ludica diciamo fare balletti cantare
cioè la cosa che tutte noi penso
facevamo da piccole anche se non c'erano
i social con le amiche ci mettono di
ballava sono le coreografie insomma cose
da da bambine da bambini sicuramente non
passare le giornate a insultare gli
altri questo veramente non ho deciso
praticamente negli ultimi giorni ha
detto basta voglio combattere questo
problema voglio aiutare chi mi segue sa
reagire e ho iniziato a condividere
sulle mie storie
i commenti di queste bambino bambini che
insomma mi insultavano sotto foto e
video ovviamente poco oscurato
l'identità ci mancherebbe altro non mi
permetterei mai quindi il nome la foto
non si vedeva e ho deciso di farlo punto
per far capire che dietro queste persone
essenzialmente c'erano delle persone
deboli e insicuri e quindi volevo che le
persone che mi seguono capissero che non
devono assolutamente aver paura di
queste persone o sentirsi attaccato da
queste persone perché insomma sono
insulti nulli sono insulti finti frutto
di noi a frutto l'insicurezza che fin
qui tutto bene
il feedback ricevuto appunto dai miei
ideali e follower stato sta positivo
ovviamente la maggior parte ha capito il
mio intento c'era c'è del bene in quello
che io voglio fare che sto facendo tanti
altri invece mi hanno attaccato perché
sono bambini ti metti al loro livello
proprio perché non dici che non te ne
frega non dovresti dargli questa
soddisfazione di magari poi le
coloriture messo nelle storie ci
rimangono male allora a se tu ti prendi
la briga di insultarmi sotto una foto
sotto un video
sinceramente non vedo perché mi devo far
problemi a far vedere il tuo commento
chiaramente oscuro l'identità però
voglio dire tanto di i [ __ ] che mi
scrivi sotto le foto sembra [ __ ] mi
fai schifo sparati e io mi devo far
problemi ma vabbè il secondo luogo
quello che queste persone in realtà che
non capiscono perché non lo faccio per
me cioè non è che faccio vedere il
commento per dire guardate questo che mi
insulta io non posso avere haters andate
a massacrarlo di insulti cioè non è
quello l'intento ma pensavo che fosse
chiaro però adesso di fare un video per
spiegare perché evidentemente non è così
chiaro l'intento è smascherare così
cyberbulli giusto oggi è successo che
una bambina aveva scritto un insulto
sotto l'ultimo post di instagram che io
ho condiviso il commento praticamente i
miei follower si sono scatenati sotto
questo commento è insomma gli hanno dato
contro dal no non dico insultata però
comunque si sono abbastanza accaniti
quindi io ovviamente ho cacciato subito
i commenti perché non era quello ciò che
volevo fare arrivare come messaggio la
cosa sorprendente che questa bambina che
si era tanto fatta la fiat a virgoletta
insultare iniziato giustificarsi ha
detto no non sono stata io e stata una
mia amica perché lei la odia perché
questa nemica odia marina io invece la
loro
no non lo farei mai e daily proprio il
punto c'è perché io faccio questo per
far vedere per smascherare queste queste
persone far vedere che dietro questi
leonida tastiere realtà ci sono degli
agnellini sono agnellini perché appena
centro ma si cagano addosso e dedico non
sono state rese giustificano quindi
questo vi fa capire che persone ci sono
dietro serve a buy cosiddetti cyber
bulli che di bullo non hanno proprio
niente perché sono degli insicuri e
questo quello che dovete capire che non
vi devono sfiorare minimamente le accuse
e gli attacchi gli insulti di queste
persone e questo chiaramente succede
quando magari un personaggio seguito a
dei follower o dei fan che iniziano
subito a difendere il personaggio in
questione ma io mi metto nei panni di
una ragazzina che riceve è un insulto di
questo tipo magari si vergogna
non so come reagire non sa cosa scrivere
preferisce non rispondere magari questa
persona anzi sicuramente cosa cyberbullo
inizia a continuare a esultare ogni post
ogni foto ogni video perché dice guarda
qua sta sfigata non ha neanche il
coraggio di rispondermi mi diverto
ok magari le amiche si possono aiutarla
ma non penso che facciano paura al
cyberbullo in questione due amiche che
difendono chiaramente la vita
quindi c'è vedete la differenza appena
vengono attaccati si cagherà addosso e
si giustifica ma chiaramente come una
bambina debole e insicura e chi mi da
bambino bambino hanno proprio la strada
spianata perché fighissimo insultare
persone che non possono reagire no cioè
come le persone che se la prendono con
gli animali come le persone che se la
prendono con gli anziani la stessa
identica cosa
quindi ho fatto questo video perché
innanzitutto voglio
assicurarvi che continuerò a combattere
insomma questo fenomeno continuerò a
mostrare i commenti di questi fantastici
cyberbulli continuerò a far passare il
messaggio di lasciarsi scivolare addosso
così commenti e continuare per la
propria strada a testa alta ma
soprattutto volevo dire una cosa a tutte
queste persone che conoscono benissimo
il fenomeno perché si sentono maestrine
sentono le psicologhe della situazione
quindi si sentono in diritto di dirmi
che è sbagliato fare così che non mi
devo mettere al loro livello che loro
sono solo bambini che quindi io sto
sbagliando tutto quanto realtà voluto
fare del bene a chi mi segue e voglio
far passare questo messaggio per
combattere il fenomeno del cyberbullismo
del bullismo
volevo dire a queste persone che mi
sveglio tutte le mattine e troppo la mia
casella di posta la possa rimanere a
chiocciola gmail.com in casata di
messaggi di ragazzine di ragazzini e
adolescenti i bambini insomma di
giovanissimi che mi chiedono aiuto
perché sono vittime di bullismo o di
cyberbullismo perché a scuola
i compagni mi fanno i dispetti risultano
fanno di tutto per per farli fermare per
farli piangere mi chiedono aiuto perché
magari queste situazioni si è mossi da
situazioni familiari poco carine gli
hanno creato disturbi alimentari
quindi mi scrivono tante bulimiche tanti
e tante anoressiche che non hanno
nessuno a cui chiedere aiuto perché
evidentemente genitori se ne fregano
ma la cosa piu grave e che mi scrivono
tantissime persone dicendomi che hanno
pensato di farla finita
quindi io vorrei dire a tutte queste
persone che si sentono tanto forti a
giudicare quello che faccio che vorrei
regalargli la responsabilità che io mi
sento addosso tutte le volte che legò
messaggi di questo tipo
tutte le volte che penso che una mia
risposta possa cambiare la situazione di
questa persona spesso io non dormo la
notte perché leggere messaggi di
ragazzini che dicono io voglio farla
finita non c'è niente che mi rende
felice al mondo
credetemi che non è facile
[Applauso]
non mi so spiegare quello che provo
quando leggo queste cose
so soltanto che sento una grande
esigenza di aiutare queste persone e
come fosse una sorta di vocazione anche
persona persona molto sensibile non
riesco a essere restare indifferente
davanti a queste cose
quindi quello che io faccio su instagram
con le mie storie con le mie lettere
chiamo ramanzine perché faccio tante
storie parlando di questo tema d'ora in
poi magari faccio video così è
e un più fruibile come contenuto
faccio tutto questo per il bene di chi
mi segue quindi non trovo carino le
vostre critiche perché è tutto il
contrario di quello che voglio fare
non fatevi buttare giù da commenti
inutili da insulti
siate fieri di voi stessi e andate
avanti per la vostra strada fregando mia
del giudizio di questa gente insicura
che purtroppo ha veramente tanti
problemi
grazie mille per aver visto tutto il
video lo so è un po lunghino però ci
tenevo tantissimo a condividere con voi
questo messaggio e c'erano tante cose da
dire ce ne sarebbero tante altre però
spero che vi basti per capire il
messaggio vi lascio qua sotto l'ala mail
alla quale potete scrivermi il mando un
bacione grandissimo e vi voglio bene
ciao ragazzi
[Musica]